affinity war is just around the corner
people Greggy Johnny
alright there's an all of them TV spot I
know that you know they can upload TV
spots on YouTube but this is from the
Marvel page in themselves so I'm like
well maybe there is something new to
offer here I don't know if we're gonna
check out all the TV spots I keep coming
out because I want to leave something
surprise even though Anthony and Joe
Russo said like we have no idea what's
really coming the first person tell me
about this TV spot is Sally Elle over at
our patreon so I want to give you a
shout out after we talk about this let's
do it
[Music]
already got to screenings to go to have
a dance once
so that's what we use
sexy except it sucks so let murder plan
and that way it might be really good
yes shut up
now like three new shots in that trip
yeah you know it's like these TV spots
are gonna be a lot of like repeat
footage with a couple of new things that
we get to see here a couple of new shots
here or there little more will conduct
cuz cuz Black Panther is the highest
grossing comic book movie in America now
yeah a little more group because that's
fun T'Challa getting a chance to show
that he will be an inspiration in this
movie he will be a guy who's motivating
for sure rig hitting the tee I'm
actually looking forward to that as much
as I was kind of uninspired by Guardians
too and and you know baby grew it's cute
I'm excited to actually see what teen
grew it's gonna be like James Gunn came
out and said that that's not the same
group that it's like his son or
something like that I forget the actual
thing that he said I believe that's what
it was you guys can correct me if I'm
wrong this is a different group that's
why it has to keep re raising it and re
teaching it the whole time it's not made
clear in guardians to I'm excited to see
what I love about these marketing spots
is that they know how to infuse their
humor so well because it's like such
epicness and yeah you get the one
callback to the official trailer with
star-lord and Iron Man having a little
quip you know they're finally here group
talking the Train and you even get like
a brief little like Spider Man zipping
through shouting woo yeah Mary Anne I
imagine we'll check out probably a
couple other TV spots while we're at it
why not you know
we already got tickets to two screenings
already so yeah you best believe we're
gonna be checking the [ __ ] out of this
movie
Sally L I really wanted to just do this
video to give you a shout out
specifically Sally is one of our most
generous patrons and we talked to each
other it's like having a pen pal I love
chatting with this woman she lives all
the way in Canada and she has this
really important government job so she's
involved in like some really important
stuff I think the thing that amazed me
most about the kind of supporter she is
I know she's a shy person I know that
she can get anxious and he getting
nervous to chat with us over like a
Google hangout or something it's just a
front G it's a front for government
secrets really Tyrone Magnus were
talking to him the thing that I find so
impressive is when she gives us feedback
she gives us feedback and so
detailed ways of like videos where
normally you might get like a comment or
to like a sentence or whatever she's
someone who seems to really understand
the the depth of a lot of the videos
that might not get the most views on our
channel more of like the discussion
based videos or the reviews or whatever
that we put more time in care and yeah
I've never seen such depth in feedback
before where I'm like wow she really
gets it she's even talked about like the
trajectory of our channel and how it
used to be a couple years ago how of the
tone and style of it is now how much he
appreciates it so Sally I just want to
say that I really appreciate the
feedback you constantly give us it makes
me feel special and even some of the
videos that might not perform as well on
this channel it's people like you that
make it feel absolutely worth doing we
usually just do those for ourselves but
to get the feedback from you and such
articulate depth makes it feel like okay
there are people who really understand
and who care you know I guess it says
makes it super rewarding and it makes it
that much more fun to make and and more
exciting to do these because you know to
have somebody catch them and feed them
back to us and it's like it's just super
rewarding you feel bit understood gee
and I know that you can get
self-conscious about the length of the
messages that we have with each other
when you send me a really long message
or whatever I just watch you know never
feel insecure about that I love love
talking to you and I love here and
everything you have to say to us thank
you for everything you've done for us
and thank you for being such a
kind-hearted and generous soul we love
the [ __ ] out of you and you'll always
have our eleven one day when we go to
Canada we are definitely gonna meet up
with you and we are taking you to a male
strip club and by male strip club I mean
John's air B&B cuz he's gonna be
separate from us I've made money as a
stripper once in my life so you know and
not to tout my skills or nothing but you
know it's I'm alright appreciate you
checking out our TV spot and Sally chef
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Meli get notified every
time one of our vids is up and we'll see
you soon can't wait for this movie